[Music]
some things are under our control
while others are not under our control
under our control
are conception choice desire aversion
and in a word everything that is our own
doing
not under our control or our body our
property
reputation office and in a word
everything that is not our own doing
furthermore the things
under our control are by nature free
unhindered and
unimpeded while the things not under our
control
are weak servile subject to hindrance
and not
our own remember therefore that if what
is naturally slavish you think to be
free
and what is not your own to be your own
you will be hampered
will grieve will be in turmoil and will
blame both gods and men
well if you think only what is your own
to be your own
and what is not your own to be as it
really is not your own
then no one will ever be able to exert
compulsion
upon you no one will ever no one will
hinder you
you will blame no one will find fault
with no one
will do absolutely nothing against your
will you will have no personal enemy
no one will harm you for neither is
there any harm
that can touch you with such high aims
therefore
remember that you must bestow yourself
with no slight effort
to lay hold of them but you will have to
give up
some things entirely and defer others
for the time being
but if you wish for these things also
and at the same time for both
office and wealth it may be that you
will not get even these ladder
because you aim also at the former and
certainly you will fail to get the
former which alone bring freedom
and happiness make it therefore
your study at the very outset to say to
every harsh
external impression you are an external
impression and not at all what you
appear to be
after that examine it and test it by
these rules which you have
the first and most important of which is
this
whether the impression has to do with
the things which are under our control
or with those which are not under our
control
and if it has to do with some one of the
things not under our control
have ready to hand the answer it is
nothing to me
chapter one of the end coridian begins
with this really
famous distinction between things that
are
in our control or under our power
in greek epi mean and things that
aren't so things that are outside of our
control that are not in
and there's a lot of ways in which this
can and has been
translated one of the most
interesting ways would perhaps to be
what is our business and what is
none of our business right when we talk
about people as
doing things or getting involved in
things that are really none of their
business
that actually fits what we're talking
about here and everything in between
when we talk about control we don't mean
control in a sort of
uh you know pathological sense of the
person who's a control freak
we mean the things that we we do control
i i decide you know whether i
flip around in the book or not right but
if i drop the book in the bathtub
i don't really control the book being
ruined
or not that's that's up to physical
processes so
you get the idea about what he's talking
about there and then when we turn to
look at
the things that epictetus tells us
in this list are in our control
you know you can see that most of them
have to do with what's inside of us or
what is a matter
of our personality our consciousness
things that are outside of our control
um some of them are going to be rather
counter-intuitive
are external to us so let's take a look
at the things that he says
are in our control conception
that's translation here of hypolasis
hoopolapsis um could also be translated
as
assumption it's it's it's what we're
working with
it's the sort of set of ideas that we're
making
sense of the world with so i see the i
have the hoopolapsis that this is a book
i also have a hoopa lapis that it is
stoic philosophy because
i've read it right um choice
jorme in greek which can also mean
impulse
uh for the stoics it means to move
towards something to choose it right
off order would be to move away from it
to reject it
aurexis which means desire
a desire in the broadest sense or even
affectivity
aversion a class that's the opposite
of desire it's you know i don't want
that so you know what are things that we
typically desire
so i may desire reading a book i may
also be averse to reading a book if i
don't want to somebody's pushing me to
what i'm really averse to that is people
telling me what to do right
and so we have all of these things going
on
inside of ourselves and then he says and
in a word
everything that is our own doing
everything
that is as he says
means you know doing deeds
uh action so the things that are up to
us this is not a complete list
by by any means they're the things that
we
have some measure of choice some measure
of control
we take a role in deciding yay or nay
what about the opposite now this is
going to be again
from a non-stoic point of view rather
counter-intuitive
not under our control our our body
so soma in greek now you might say
wait a second i decide what i'm gonna do
with my body
that's true i decide whether i'm going
to shower
or wash it or take care of it
aptitudes would say yeah that's that's
perfectly correct you do decide
what you do with your body i decide
whether i go to the doctor or not
whether i do
preventive medicines or like preventive
maintenance on a
vehicle or a tool or something like that
right
an advocate would say you're completely
correct
but you can still get hit by the bus and
you can still
die of cancer and you can still have all
sorts of things happen to your body
that you really do not have control over
you have some measure of control over
your body
but you don't call all the shots the way
that you can with things having to do
with your consciousness now you might
also say well
wait a second what about people who have
a chemical imbalance well if
if you think that that's coming from the
body you don't control
your body in that case right and that
could affect your
your mind as well what else
our property so you know this book again
if i drop this into the bathtub
and all the pages get screwed up
i don't control that i can't snap my
fingers and say pages
fix yourself or something like that
people can come along and steal our
property our property is very vulnerable
what else reputation
that's a very important one we tend to
think that we
do control our reputation doksai
in greek you know the opinion that other
people have about us
um office or power
or position we often say archive
in greek right which means things like
holding public office
but if we think about our own uh world
today you know do you get promoted to
manager or not
that's not completely up to you i mean
you can definitely make sure that you
won't get promoted to manager
by acting like like a screw-up but even
if you do everything the way that you're
supposed to
maybe there's no job great example of
this is in contemporary academia
a lot more applicants than there are
positions available unless you want to
do
adjunct work and you don't control that
that's not
up to you if it was it wouldn't be like
that
so he says in a word everything that is
not
our own doing what does that mean if
it's not our own doing if it's not our
own
ergo in greek that means it's up to
somebody or
something else to call the shots
to make the decisions about it to
determine it
so if it's the weather while it's these
vast complex systems
that we don't actually have not only
much control over we actually don't
understand
all that well we can't predict uh way
ahead of time
the way that we might like to but um
if it's about whether or not you get the
promotion it's about all these other
factors
or whether you get a good performance
review or you know whether somebody
gives me a thumbs up or thumbs down in
this video
not in my control so
he goes on and he's and he draws a very
important conclusion from this
he says furthermore the things under our
control
have certain characteristics they are
by nature by the way that they're
constituted
by reality we might say sometimes it's
useful to substitute
the way that we talk about reality for
nature
when we're reading stoic tests by nature
these things are
free unhindered and unimpeded
now what does he mean by that well if we
think about for example our assumptions
or our choices
or our desires and our aversions again
it often feels like these are just
imposed upon us but epictetus says no no
we we have some measure of control we
have some measure of choice
when it comes to these if i decide
that i am no longer going to choose
to smoke or that every night i am going
to
drink a cup of tea
a glass of tea in this case that is up
to me
the only thing that can prevent me from
doing that
other than things keeping me from
getting t is myself
what about the other things he says
things
not under our control are and he's got
an interesting set of
qualifiers are weak
servile subject to hindrance and not our
own
even if we do enjoy them even if we
think we do have some
measure of say so in them
it's not to a great degree so think
about your body again
for instance you can work out all you
want and then suddenly die of a heart
attack
there that happens to quite a few people
you can
um you know decide i'm going to lose
weight
and go on this great diet and i'm going
to feel so great
and then it turns out that the food that
you're eating you develop an allergy to
all these things are are possibilities
because it's not really under your
control
so he draws another conclusion
that's really at the heart of stoic
philosophy here
remember therefore that if what is
naturally slavish
what is naturally determined by another
where there's somebody else saying you
do it this way
you think to be free and what is not
your own to be your own
you will be hampered things are going to
get in your way
you will grieve you will be in turmoil
and you will blame both gods and human
beings
so if we get this distinction wrong
if we follow what say society or
culture or advertising in our own time
advertising creates for us all sorts of
mistaken conceptions
about what's good and bad what we really
do we have control over
you know for instance if you think that
by going and buying some
product you're actually going to
assure for yourself uh success in the
workplace
or uh you know suitable mate
or friends around you or a great time
watching the super bowl or anything like
that
you're really setting yourself up for
some major disappointment for some
turmoil
like he said and we have a choice
about whether we do that or not we
aren't simply
robots dictated by
our programming we are able to
to some degree go in and reconfigure our
programming but we have to understand
how the human being is set up we have to
engage in what he's doing here
which is what we call philosophical
anthropology or the study
of human nature so
he goes on and he says um
if you think only what is your own to be
your own
and what is not your own to be as it
really is not your own
then things are going to be different
then
no one will ever be able to exert
compulsion on you
if you stick to what you actually do
have control over
and you don't worry about the things
that you don't have control over
other people won't be able to push you
around in any meaningful way
as epictetus says in another place in
the discourses
well you know you you can take my body
and do what you're going to do with it i
you know i can't really prevent you from
doing that but that's my body that's not
me when it comes to me
you can't make me decide that what's
wrong is right and what's right is wrong
or what's true is false and what's false
is true
the only way you can make me do that is
if i myself
collaborate in the process
so if we follow this distinction
nobody's going to be able to compel us
he goes on
and he says no one will hinder you
nobody's going to get in your way think
about
how many times we find ourselves
feeling frustrated because we want
things to go a certain way
and somebody keeps that from happening
those of you who drive
think about what the act of driving from
place to place is like
not only do you have the other drivers
on the road and the road conditions
sometimes the road doesn't even go where
you want it to go
there's cones set up oh you can't go
that way the bridge is out
well if you decide that you weren't
really
you were only planning on ongoing if it
was going to be possible for you
rather than i have to get there you're
not going to be hindered it's not
you that's being hindered it could be
your car
he goes on as well he says you'll blame
no one you're not going to get upset
with other people right you're not going
to criticize
you're not going to get angry and shout
all that is condensed into what he's
calling blaming
he says you will find fault with no one
you will do
absolutely nothing against
your will
that's an interesting one and that's
worth dwelling on and thinking about
for a while how is it that you're not
going
to be pushed or pulled or prodded
into doing anything against your own
will
whether you live in a world of things
that are constantly impinging on you
well if you stick to what you actually
do have control over
you have control over that if you choose
to desire the wrong thing
that's your choice you're not being
compelled against your will
or cajoled or seduced because the only
reason anybody
can seduce you or compel you
is because you give in that's what
epictetus is saying here
but you give in because you mistake what
is under your control for what is not
under your control
and you place the good in things that
are not under your control
he says you'll have no personal enemy
no one will harm you for neither is
there
any harm that can touch you
that's also worth thinking about how is
it
that in a world in which we're so
vulnerable in so many different ways
nobody can harm you well the question
there is what is the you
what is being harmed if you think that
you are your body
well of course you can be harmed i can
poke you in the eye
or stab you through the heart or crush
your toes or do
all sorts of other things and you can do
them to me too of course you can't
through the camera
but you know imagine you had a button
that let you do that sort of thing
right if it's your property wow you're
totally vulnerable
not only can you know somebody come
along and steal it or whether screw it
up
the state can come in and take your your
property as well
there's all sorts of vulnerabilities
reputation
online presence if epictetus were around
today
he would say your social media profile
is not up to you
that is something that really is outside
of your control
so he says with such high aims therefore
remember that you must bestow yourself
with no slight effort to lay hold of
them
to keep these things in mind
but you will have to give up some things
entirely
if you want to stick to these principles
and you want to follow this through in a
practical way you can't just do whatever
you want
you will also have to defer to put off
others for the time being
now notice what else he says you have to
make a kind of
choice if you wish for these things
also what's good what's fundamentally
good what will make us free
what is within our control
but as he says at the same time you also
wish for wealth for property
prosperity in
office to hold power
to be in charge it may be that you will
not even get
these things those are often
up to other people right those aren't
depends those aren't
uh up to us entirely we can sort of
prime the pump
but we can't necessarily get those
things just by making a decision for
them whatever
people may tell us out there about oh
you just have to want it hard enough or
work hard enough
you can work as hard as you want in some
cases
and still die a pauper you can
work as hard as you want and make
friends with everybody and nobody gives
you a position
and if you're going to pursue those
things like he says
you're not going to get the other things
that you do
recognize to be good like peace of mind
like tranquility like a
moral faculty what you really are
in accordance with with nature and he
says
um you will aim also at the
former and certainly you'll fail to get
the former which alone bring freedom
and happiness you're not going to get it
you have to make a decision are you
going to pursue the things
of the external world are you going to
use those as your criteria
is that going to establish your set of
priorities or are you going to focus on
the things that really
are within your power and do the best
that you can with them
you can't do both epictetus is saying
so he goes on and now he he tells us
about something
a little bit different he's he's
changing the topic slightly in this
passage
it says make it there for your study at
the very outset
to say to every harsh external
appearance the greek for that
is fontasia and when we're translating
it as external appearance we mean
something that's impinging on us from
the outside
but because it's fontasia you could just
as well
say that we're talking about is our
imagination because that's
also what fontasia means uh things that
impinge upon us things that
seem a certain way to us that we imagine
to be
that that way
we could have hold trains of
imaginations together
right the oh my gosh the world is
falling in
because this is terrible and this is
terrible this is terrible
that's a whole chain of fontasiai
or impressions together and he says
whenever
something like that confronts us this is
what we ought to do
we tell it we talk to it we say
you are an external impression and not
at all what you appear to be
you don't know maybe it could be what it
appears to be
but not necessarily so so
the the cup of tea
could have gone cold it's not it's it's
actually warm
if it goes cold and i say oh my goodness
oh this is so
terrible who wants to drink cold tea i
mean people do drink iced tea in other
circumstances
but when we want hot tea we really want
hot tea and not cold tea right
oh the whole thing is ruined the meal is
ruined
the whole evening is ruined epicurus is
saying
okay when things like that are pushing
themselves on you when you're
getting these imaginations you can say
to them wait a second
now maybe you're right but
maybe you're not right maybe you're just
an impression
and you're not what you pretend to be
i'll actually check it out
and see whether that's the case so he
says
after you examine it and test it
by these rules that you have by these
criteria
the the greek is actually kanon which
means something like a measuring
stick right when we talk about the
canons of a discipline
what are the canons they are the things
in the end caribbean the stoic velocity
when you use stoic philosophy
to tell whether or not your you know
external
impressions are vertical or whether
they're
full of you know what or maybe somewhere
in between
then you can actually get to the bottom
of things
and then you can have the better
response so it says after you examine it
and test it
the first and most important of these
rules is this
does this impression have to do with the
things which are under our control
or those which are not under our control
and if it is something
that's not under our control we should
have
ready at hand the answer and when he
when he talks about having ready at hand
this means we should have in our mental
toolbox as we say
we should be equipped with being able to
trot out for ourselves what the stoics
called a
dogma we get a the word dogmatic from
that people think it's bad to be
dogmatic
what it really means for ancient greek
philosophy to be dogmatic
is to have ready at hand you know a
whole supply
of things that you can use to make sense
of the world
and to get yourself out of trouble
so what is the thing that we want to
have at hand
it is nothing to me so again if we want
to use the example you know the tea
oh you know i'm so so glad i've got some
hot tea
it's gonna be so wonderful
the tea is cold the night is ruined i
can't possibly stand this
as a kid say i can't even right
what we can do and what epictetus is
saying to us is hey
slow it down you don't have to follow
along that line of reasoning
let's take a look at what's going on
here and
let's apply this principle was that
something in my control or was that
something out of my control
whether or not the tea gets warm and
stays warm or gets cold
pretty much up to physical phenomena
it's not subject to my will
i certainly can't desire that it remain
hot but that
desire by itself does nothing to heat
the tea or to conserve its heat or
anything like that
and if i think it does i'm nuts right
and many of us are nuts in this way a
lot of the time
and part of what's the you know the
whole task of stoicism
is hey let's be less nuts one way we can
do that is we say
was that something under my control no
fine then it doesn't matter it's
nothing to me it doesn't matter one way
it doesn't matter another way notice
what he's not doing here he's not saying
it's all garbage it's nothing in the
sense like you are dead to me or
anything like that
that's still reactive this is
dissociative
in a certain sense i'm just not going to
be entangled
at least in the sense of how i feel and
how i think and whether i have
calm within myself or whether i allow
myself to be upset
i'm not going to allow myself to be
entangled with whether tea is hot or
cold
i've got bigger fish to fry like my own
psyche and the fact that it steers me
into thinking that tea
actually matters so
that provides you with i think a useful
example and you can come up with lots of
other examples
to make sense out of this passage with
on your own
but notice that what he's been talking
about here
and playing off of is this fundamental
distinction
what is in our power or under our
control what is not in our power
two different opposites an important
distinction
that we have to get right or we're going
to be steered astray